et de la verrière on passe à saint-cir
l'école bonsoir Bernard Debin vous êtes
le maire UMP de saint-cire l'école bonne
année à vous on parlera principalement
du futur quartier de la zacrenard qui va
accueillir à terme 1500 logements
parlera peut-être un peu des municipales
également c'est dans une quinzaine de
mois mais peut-être vous préparez-vous
déjà vous nous le direz ou pas en tout
cas je vous propose déjà de découvrir un
chiffre le chiffre de ce de janvier le
chiffre de cette édition
1435448 c'est le nombre d'ivelinois en
2000 12 l'Institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques
Linc vient de communiquer les derniers
chiffres du recensement une progression
de 2001 habitants en 1 an la ville du
département qui a le plus progressé
c'est celle de trappe plus 2,62 % en
revanche à sainè l'école 0,78 % que
s'est-il passé à sain-ciire il y a moins
d'habitants à saint-ciè l'école en 2012
qu'il y en avait en 2011
17976 sainérien saérien
ah je vous l' prends là vous m'apprenez
quelque chose alors maintenant ça me
paraît bizarre fara que je vois les les
chiffres parce
que j'ai quand même une opposition qui
m'accuse de bétonner à oututrance je
savais pas encore que j'avais une
truelle mais bon or en ce qui concerne
les constructeurs il y a pourtant eu des
chantiers cette année à
sincir
peut-être un petit peu moins que en 2010
ou en 2011 mais il y en a quand même eu
et cette baisse me paraît un peu bizarre
euh est-ce qu'on prend les mêmes chires
est-ce que parce que si vous voulez dans
le chiffre de 18102 habitants que nous
avions il y a les 500 élèves du lycée
militaire qui son alors on est sur
17976 habitants alors vous voyez
effectivement faudrait regarder le
détail sur le calcul précis mais c'est
en tout cas à peu près stable et ça
pourrait augmenter ça pourrait en tout
cas augmenter dans les prochaines années
avec les prochaines réalisations not
notamment du côté de la zacrenard ça on
va en parler dans un instant juste un
autre chiffre ce chiffre c'est 28 c'est
le nombre de voitures incendiées durant
la nuit de la Saint-Sylvestre dans le
département des ivelines est-ce que la
nuit a était calme à saint-cir l'école
la nuit du réveillon la nuit a était
calme très bien on va faire le point
avec Catherine zulato dans le reste du
département alors pour voir les points
où la situation a été plus
compliquée comme l'avait promis manuel
Vals le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
cette fin d'année 2012 les chiffres des
véhicules incendiés ont été communiqués
dans les ivelines à la préfecture a
recensé pour cette soirée du réveillon
du Nouvel An 28 voitures brûlées et 13
autres par propagation sit un total de
41 cinq personnes ont été interpellées
pour fait de violence le préfet a estimé
dans un communiqué de presse que la
situation a été globalement calme en ce
qui concerne la sécurité routière cette
fois aucun mort n'est à déplorer sur les
routes du département en la matière de
nouvelles mesures sont annoncé en ce
début d'année comme la mise en place des
nouveaux radars tronçons trois en tout
en Vallée de Chevreuse et en forêt de sa
Saint-Germain en
lait Bernard deain le maire de Saint-Ser
l'école est donc l'invité de ce 2
janvier du 78 première édition de
l'année 2013 le dossier de la zacronar
qui avance enfin cette ancienne base
militaire surans votre commune de 25
haectares c'est 5 % de la commune de la
superficie va devenir un tout nouveau
quartier le terrain a été vendu fin
décembre par l'État à l'aménageur à
l'agence foncière et technique de la
région parisienne on va voir les images
d'ailleurs de de cette signature qui
s'est déroulée fin décembre l'idée même
de cette transformation remonte à plus
de 10 ans qu'est-ce qui explique ce ce
retard pour finalement aboutir sur cette
signature c'est même plus de 10
ans c'est un projet qui a commencé à gmé
il y a effectivement une dizaine
d'années mais qui a commencé à
être
véritablement lancé en 2003 donc nous on
va on va arriver au 10 ans maintenant
qu'est-ce qui explique ce ce délai est
aussi long pour aujourd'hui finalement
aboutir à cette signature entre l'État
et l'aménageur alors la première des
choses c'est que c'était un terrain
occupé puisqu'il y avait une base
aérienne il y avait des bâtiments donc
une fois que la décision a été prise par
les autorités militaires premièrement
ont démoli deuxièmement il y a eu pour
le la réglementation appliquée la
l'amiante à retiré c'était des vieux
bâtiments et puis ensuite toute la
campagne de dépollution pyrotechnique
qui s'est é allé sur près de 3 ans et il
y a des mauvaises surprises sur ce voilà
avec des disons qu'on savait un peu vu
ce qui était tombé voilà durant la
guerre effectivement il a fallu donc
ensuite déminer il y a eu de grosses
opérations qui ont été organisées sur
votre commune on va parler de l'avenir
de ce site on revient tout de même
quelques jours en arrière ce 21 décembre
la date de la signature en mairie
reportage sur des images d'éod di Mo et
de Patrick Jacques de
dixm 12 ans après le lancement du projet
les premiers logements de la zacrenard à
senscir les école pourrait enfin voir le
jour des premières livraisons fin 2015
c'est en tout cas le souhait de l'AFRT
l'agence foncière et technique de la
région parisienne propriétaire des
terrains de l'ancienne caserne depuis le
21 décembre dernier elle a déboursé 16,8
million d'euros pour racheter les
terrains à l'état notre rôle c'est un
d'acheter le terrain donc c'est l'étape
d'aujourd'hui euh deuxièmement c'est
d'aménager le terrain d'y amener les
voiries les les réseaux l'assainissement
l'eau et cetera d'y réaliser tous les
espaces publics euh place espace vert et
autres et puis c'est de revendre ensuite
par l'eau à des constructeurs promoteurs
qui viendront construire des pour
l'essentiel des logements sur ce site à
terme un écoquartier de 1450 logements
et ses équipement public la ville
gardera un contrôle sur la réalisation
la mairie elle a un contrôle qui découle
de la concession
d'aménagement sur à la fois le nombre de
appartement le nombre de maisons
individuelles le nombre d'accession à la
propriété et aussi sur les équipements
public puisque il y a près de 8 millions
d'équipements publics qui vont être
construits seulement du côté de
l'opposition on estime ne pas avoir
encore assez d'éléments la présentation
du projet n'étant prévu en Conseil
Municipal que le 15 janvier autre point
qui pose problème le coût trop élevé du
terrain pourrait entraîner un prix de
logement excessif pour la population à
s'insir dans les logements sociaux il y
a plein de gens qui en fait sont
au-dessus des vraies conditions pour
être dans lement social mais ne peuvent
pas être dans le le privé parce que le
le saut financier est trop important
qu'est-ce qu'a fait l'aménageur il a
monté les prix ce qui veut dire que tout
ce logement dit intermédiaire on le
retrouve plus dans la ZAC quelque part
Bernard Debin peut dire moi je contrôle
la situation en réalité il vient de
laisser perdre une occasion de créer un
type de logement qui nous manque dans la
ville 10 ans seront nécessaires pour la
réalisation complète de ce nouveau
quartier mais avant que les premières
bétonneuses n'arrivent une dernière des
pollution industrielle est prévu en
2013 et Bernard Debin qui est en plateau
va pouvoir répondre aux différents
points qui ont été abordés dans ce
reportage tout d'abord sur la
communication globale sur les différents
éléments qui sont transmis en conseil
municipal par exemple votre opposition
une partie de l'opposition qui nous dit
qui soulligne en tout cas via différents
communiqué qu'elle n'a pas accès à cette
information qu'on ne le présente pas les
projets quelle est votre réponse sur ce
pointl déjà est-ce que vous communiquez
suffisamment ben écoutez à chaque fois
qu'il demande quelque chose il l'ont
euh il y a si on parle de ce projet là
par exemple il était bien entendu que il
y a certaines choses qui ne pouvaient
pas être communicables pour et c'était
une demande à la fois des militaires de
l'autorité du service des Domaines
c'est-à-dire eux qui fixent le prix pour
l'État et puis de l'aménageur puisqueil
y a quand même des choses qui était
confidentielle étant donné qu'il lançait
un appel d'offre à différents
constructeurs donc si vous voulez tant
que ce n'était pas fait on ne pouvait
pas communiquer d'autant plus que rien
n'est figé même encore à l'heure
actuelle on est en on se voit à peu près
une fois tous les 3 semaines pour des
réunions de 3 4 heures tous les 3
semaines pour définir quel type de
logements vont être
fait quels architectes tout ce genre de
choses donc euh on on va dire quelque
chose qui ne sera plus valable un mois
après ou 2 mois après voilà justement
vous parliez des types de logement
est-ce qu'on a entendu dans ce reportage
de la part de Daniel Farnier justement
qui un des opposants d'un des
conseillers municipal de d'opposition il
parle d'un prix de vente trop cher du
terrain ce qui vous a d'ailleurs fait
bondir pendant le reportage d'un prix de
vente trop élevé qui pourrait entraîner
du coup en cascade des logements trop
chers puisque ensuite maintenant que
l'État a vendu le terrain un aménageur
l'aménageur va se charger de son travail
c'est-à-dire d'aménager et puis ensuite
il va vendre à des promoteurs mais il
vendra forcément plus cher il va falloir
qu'il équilibre ses comptes et donc le
promoteur derrière mettra des logements
plus chers est-ce que c'est une bonne
logique ou pas est-ce que c'est comme ça
que ça va alors non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe euh premièrement le prix
des logements c'est le prix du marché
hein aès on peut choisir de faire
excusez-moi mais on peut choisir de
faire du haut de gamme du milieu de
gamme ou de l'entrée des des prix
sociaux alors bon d'abord quand même
rappeler que ça à 2600 logements sociaux
ce qui est déjà un peu plus de 40 % donc
ça c'est pour les logements sociaux que
nous allons quand même en faire un peu
plus d'une centaine sur ce sur ce site
alors que nous n'y sommes pas obligés
que nous allons faire plus d'une
centaine d'accession à la propriété donc
des prix inférieurs et puis le prix des
logement ben c'est le marché
c'est-à-dire ce que les les acheteurs je
suppose que ceux qui construisent c'est
pour que ils soi vendus donc ils le
mettront pas trop cher et en ce qui
concerne les les constructeur il faut
savoir que la ftrp donc l'aménageur a
fait faire une espèce d'appel d'offre et
c'est ceux qui ont été qu'on appelle les
mieux disants qui l'ont emporté voilà
c'estz sur les logements qui vont voir
le jour est-ce que vous avez un contrôle
vous savez quel type de logement vont
finalement être ré exctement exactement
ça par contre on le sait et qu est votre
volonté justement d'avoir une certaine
mixité d' c'est nous qui on alors euh on
a le choix on a eu on a eu le choix des
architectes par un certain nombre de
cabinets d'architecture nous ont été
présentés chaque architect est venu avec
un espèce de Bou hein euh bah celui-là
on n veut pas non pas celui-là et autre
et maintenant qu'on les a devant nous je
vois la dernière réunion on nous a
présenté des constructions avec avec des
espèces de clostras et la mêle en bois
que l'on met devant les balcons ça fait
faire des économies ça coûte pas très
cher je trouve ça affreux je l'ai dit ma
responsable de l'urbanisme trouvé ça
affreux ça vieillit mal il y a des
difficultés d'entretien on lui a dit
vous pouvez repartir avec votre copie
revenez la prochaine fois la prochaine
fois ça va être dans quelques jours donc
on a quand même un œil un regard s vous
ça c'est sur le le logement sur
l'apparence globale des
bâtimentspe de lement mais ça c'est
défini depuis 5 ans dans le traité de
concession et ça là l'opposition le sait
parfaitement puisque le traité de
concession elle l'a voté en conseil
maintenant s'ils ont égaré les papiers
on va leur redonner donc il y aura du
logement accessible on va dire il y a
desaccessions à la propriété je crois
que ça tourne autour de 250 hein sur
1450 c'est quand même pas négligeable il
y a plus d'une centaine de logements
sociaux je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
et puis euh si vous voulez ce qui ce
qu'il fallait assincir aussi c'est une
certaine rééquilibrage par rapport aux
2500 et quelques logements sociaux que
nous avons la ville a besoin aussi
d'avoir un peu d'argent les logements
sociaux ne payent pas de taxe foncière
ils sont exemptés même s'ils couvrent
une très grande surface de la ville or
nous nous avons besoin impérativement
d'avoir des rentrées puisque nous
n'avons pas de commerce nous n'avons pas
d'entreprise j'espère que nous allons en
avoir ça avance ça progresse la
zacrenard en fait partie mais il y a pas
qu'elle puisque il y a trois endroits
dans la ville qui sont en cours
d'aménagement quel type de logement
attendent les saint-cériens les
saint-cérienn nous sommes allés poser la
question tout simplement dans les rues
de votre ville un peu plus de commerce
sur tout puis des appartements sociaux
si possible peut-être sportif aussi je
pense que des écoles primaires ça serait
vraiment top réaménager ça pour les
logements sociaux d'une part et
permettre quelques personnes de de plus
dormir dehors bah des petits immeubles
et des
infrastructures qui pourrait nous faire
payer un peu moins d'impôts ce serait
bien s'il y a plus d'entreprises sinci
ce serait bien j'aimerais des des beaux
logements du style de ceux qui sont au
parc de
laabay avec avec quand
même une petit un petit parc autour
parce que je pense qu'il y a la place
mais je sais ce que les saint-serniers
attendent je
pense chacun sa vision une petite
réaction sur ce qui a été dit c'est
l'ensemble de la ville c'est si vous
voulez c'est tout à fait compréhensible
les personnes qui
cherche avoir un appartement dans les
les logements sociaux c'est normal qu'
qu'ils en réclament plus donc c'est pour
ça que je vous ai dit qu'il y en aura
quand même et puis il y a aussi
euh on a parlé de de verdure d'espace
vert c'est un quartier très vert encore
plus vert que le quartier de l'abaye qui
a é constr et ne serait-ce que parce que
pour des raisons historiques il y a ce
qu'on appelle le trident Gabriel qui
part de la cour de l'école militaire et
qui entre autres rejoint l'étoile royale
dans le parc de Versailles et ce
tridempfle c'est des allées de 50 m de
large qui sont inconstructibles donc
déjà de la verdure il y en aura mais il
y aura pas que là il y en aura partout
on va parler des équipements publics
aussi peut-être avec un autre point
puisque vous répondiez à ces différentes
critiques notamment ces différents
points qui concernent ce quartier de la
zacrenard alors c'est un dossier un peu
plus technique ça concerne les
subventions pour les équipements on va
écouter à nouveau une dernière fois
Daniel Farnier et puis vous lui
répondrez nous avons signé dans l'acte
de vente de l'achat des terrains de
l'ensemble de la ZAC que si nous avons
des subventions sur les équipements
publicqus on les reverse donc c'est ce
que financeraiit ces subventions en
réalité c'est pas la construction c'est
l'acquisition du terrain de la ZAC et
donc bien au-delà des terrains on est
dans une mécanique qui va pas marcher
quelque part les financeurs ils se
doivent je prend le président du conseil
général il peut pas faire n'importe quoi
les subventions es ont été approuvées
par l'assemblée départementale il y a un
règlement il y a des conditions or ces
conditions vous pouvez les regarder très
simplement sur les sites internet du
Conseil Général du Conseil régional
elles sont massivement pour la
construction si on avait pas cette
condition qui a été rajoutée la commune
pourrait les toucher à améliorer les
équipements mais là on a signé qu'en
fait ces subventions en réalité vont
servir à l'acquisition de l'ensemble des
terrains de LAAC c'est là que ça ne va
pas alors est-ce que c'est là que ça ne
va pas est-ce que ces subventions vont
permettre justement d'embellir en tout
cas de réaliser ces aménagements publics
où est-ce que ça permettra d'acquérir du
terrain et c'est là où ce n'est pas
possible en fonction au regard des
textes de loi ce que dit votre
opposition alors les subventions elles
sont versées lorsque vous avez un projet
projet de gymnase projet d'école projet
de crèche pour aider la commune à cette
construction la commune là on lui verse
on lui donne ses équipements clé en main
terminé donc on va pas aller demander de
l'argent pour quelque chose qui est
construit par quelqu'un d'autre vous
comprenez donc il est normal que si cet
argent est éligible à une subvention il
là il y a celui qui construit et là pour
des raisons de
de prix si vous voulez ce n'est pas le
constructeur c'està-dire la ftrp qui va
le toucher c'est l'état c'est de
l'argent qui doit revenir à l'état
puisque l'État estime qu'il a pas vendu
le terrain cher faites le calcul 17
millions de prix de vente divisé par 25
hectares l'état l'a pas vendu cher il a
la dépollution aussi du site dans le C
oui mais même avec une dépollution si
vous voulez mais c'est pas un terrain
qui est vendu cher quand on sait le prix
du terrain ne ser
saincir c'est pas cher du tout pour vous
c'est une bonne opération pour la
commune ah c'est une opération
extraordinaire pour la commune alors
actuelle on avait une ville qui vers le
nord s'arrêtait à l'avenue jean-jorè
c'est-à-dire devant l'école militaire
derrière ça appartenait à l'école
militaire et après il y avait plus rien
il y avait que un boulevard une avenue
du Général de Gaulle
maisvecien là on va prolonger la ville
on 5 % de plus c'est 25 c'est c'est un
nouveau quartier ce n'est pas une
nouvelle ville c'est un nouveau quartier
et c'est là notre gageur c'est de faire
en sorte que les quartiers que ça va
réunir c'est-à-dire aussi bien à l'est
qu'à l'ouest ne fassent qu'un au bout
d'un certain temps et que tout le monde
puisse se rencontrer il faudra 10 ans
pour que ce quartier soit pleinement
réalisé environ 2015 pour les premières
livraisons toute dernière question sur
ce dossier la priorité sera donnée aux
habitants de saint-ciè pour
l'acquisition alors pour en ce qui
concerne
l'accession à la propriété oui c'est
impératif et euh le beaucoup de
saintsyriens sont ceux qui se sont déjà
réinstallés lorsque il y a eu la
création de la ZAC de l'abay et je pense
que là aussi c'est pour beaucoup qui ont
besoin de de s'agrandir l'occasion de
rester à saint-ire parce que je crois
que c'est une ville où il fait bon vivre
et Bernard Deb on va parler politique
avec vous à présent les municipales
c'est dans un peu plus non vous allez
nous dire on l'espère si vous serez
candidat ou non